Who I am is the guy who's not fast
enough to stop well he hasn't been one
step ahead of us no he's been a thousand
I can't catch him Wells he's here you
can't beat me Barry
hope we're not too late
you can't fight all three of us at the
same time this is gonna be fun
if not be narrow bury the accelerator
it's been reactivated must be pretty
desperate to come asking for my
assistance do it hey youtubers it's
Charlie so new flash footage for next
week so there's gonna be a breakdown to
that and I have some details on the
spin-off series too as well as Supergirl
so what I've done here is I've actually
jammed the Canadian trailer onto the
other extended trailer just because they
have different footage the name of the
episode is rogue air as you may have
guessed there are rogues in it we see
Barry going to get some help from
Captain Cold because he's not strong
enough or fast enough to beat Wells
really the biggest surprise for me or
that the Amell cousins are in the
episode I actually thought they weren't
gonna show up till the finale it's
totally possible they could be in both
the final episodes in 22 and episode 23
remember Wells is hiding out beneath the
particle accelerator getting ready to
activate it as it looks like he does in
episode 22 I know a lot of you were
wondering whether or not turning this
back on is a backdoor to giving Caitlin
snow her metahuman abilities turning her
into killer frost she had this really
interesting line in last week's gras
depa sowed where she's like I wonder how
Grodd could have turned so evil the
answer to that is because of the stuff
that Eiling did to him and because of
what Wells did to him after the fact
nature versus nurture
if Caitlin is going to become a villain
something really crazy is going to have
to happen because that is a dramatic
left turn for her maybe it has something
to do with firestorm we actually found
out the reason why Robbie Amell isn't
listed on the cast for the spin-off show
which actually just got picked up for
series yeah everybody Martin Stein is
going to separate permanently from
firestorm he said some things that
implied that firestorm is going to have
to merge with someone else to form the
matrix again so we might see Jason Rusch
come back he actually guest-starred on
the first episode of iZombie he was like
the mistress of a bunch of prostitutes
which i think is kind of funny this is
actually the trailer moment that made
everybody poop their pants the
reverse-flash using his Flash rank to
put the suit on I totally think we're
gonna see Barry do this in season 2 at
some point they have to upgrade the suit
they have to give him the white logo and
he has to get the ring at some point he
might steal it from the reverse
flashed in the finale that might be how
he gets it talk about paradox because
how did he get it the first time
if the reverse-flash got it from Barry
Allen in the past so there are two big
things going on in the episode a bunch
of rogues break out of the metahuman
prison probably just another distraction
from wells to keep team flash busy so
flash in answer goes and gets help from
Captain Cold
heatwave and golden Collider their
actions in this episode will give you an
idea of what they might be doing in the
spin-off series because the synopsis for
the spin-off series says that rip hunter
comes back in time to assemble a team of
villains and heroes to help avert like
some really catastrophic future event
make as many Infinite Crisis jokes as
you want will probably it some more news
about the spin-off next week but that's
something else altogether just on the
flash Captain Cold is probably gonna
swap teams until he double-crosses the
flash he's a man of opportunity so even
if he helps him out in episode 22 I
don't expect him to walk away in episode
23 without gaining something but the
reverse-flash professor zoom himself is
famous for hating rogues so it just it
makes sense that there would be a rogue
team up against the reverse-flash at
some point as far as we know the roads
breaking out that we're gonna see
include rainbow Raider the mist death
bolt weather wizard and peekaboo so
is going down add to that that Eddy
looks like he is freakin pissed and he's
out he gets out somehow maybe the
reverse flash releases and knowing he's
already done his damage when you know
the future you don't have to worry so
much about keeping people locked up the
fun thing too is that general Eiling is
back surprisingly I mean he probably
comes back to try and help round up all
the Rogues
because this is a crazy situation it
explains why they need Oliver and
firestorm to help out for everyone
wondering about the arrow flash timeline
it's a little confusing because how can
Oliver in his League of Assassins gear
be in Central City and be in the middle
of his wedding in episode 22 of arrow so
it's probably gonna happen is is the
events of these episodes will overlap a
little bit
that's just my best guess though the
producers haven't explained it they
could have just derped in this moment
where all of us here now could take
place after the arrow finale it just
seems like Oliver is gonna be spending
most of the arrow finale on the plane
with Rachel Gold trying to keep him from
releasing the bio weapon on Starling
city but there's just like a huge amount
of crossover happening between the arrow
in the flash and the finale so it's
gonna be a lot of fun
and really awesome thing to get excited
about so they're gonna have a promo for
the spin-off series that'll air after
the flash finale for those wondering I
will do more bonus videos for that
especially once we get the trailer it's
gonna be a limited series like you know
13 episodes and it will start airing in
January sometime so like around the same
time agent Carter season 2 premieres
probably we don't know what day it's
gonna air on though but if the CW
follows suit you know with the way it
normally does things it'll be on a
different day from air on the flash so
lots of stuff to get excited about be
sure to subscribe to get my video for
next week I'm also gonna do a video for
the arrow finale trailer - next and
don't worry us to do a Q&A video there
been a whole bunch of big TV
announcements so you guys can follow me
on Twitter and Facebook for a lot of
that stuff just because you know a lot
of it isn't quite big enough to make a
video for yet just an update on
Supergirl - it was picked up they just
haven't announced what day it's gonna
air on once they do I'll do a new video
for it so lots of Supergirl stuff coming
it's gonna be a lot of fun it's been a
really big day I did a big Captain
America's Civil War video this morning
you can click here to watch it they
announced pretty much everybody that's
gonna be in the movie and it's like
every character you've ever heard of
ever and you can click here for this
week's episode of the flash and arrow
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tomorrow
you